hi everyone i'm up early this morning
for a hike and i thought it's been a
while since i've done any videos so i
decided to do a bit of a channel update
and give you an idea of what's coming up
for 2022.
to start with i've got some travel
related videos from a recent trip to
thailand i visited some amazing
waterfalls and beaches which were really
quiet due to pandemic
in terms of aikido i've got some
tutorials with sensei paul lowen and
i've also got a couple of videos
exploring some new ideas with the joe
with regards to my search for katanas to
use for sparring well i finally got some
i plan to post that footage as well as a
review of the swords themselves
i also plan to film some videos of the
cannonball of mace and look at the
relationship between them and other
weapons
so plenty in store for the next few
months
if you've got any questions leave them
down below to finish with i'd just like
to thank all subscribers for your
continued support i really appreciate it
i'm just about to hit 2 000 subs which
is much more than i expected when i
first started the channel six years ago
anyway that just about wraps it up for
this video i hope you enjoyed it and i
hope you also enjoy these amazing views
[Music]
you